so again working uh with just the skills
okay so uh we're not gonna use the grip
there's there's no push
pull there's no push pulling ikea
um there's adhesion or projection
okay so we i don't stick your hand up
okay
and then he's going to give some energy
and i want to make sure that it goes in
his in his center
you see that so i don't wanna just pull
you
okay so i'm projecting you see that
it'll affect his cesar like that
okay there he goes it'll affect his
stays up
uh this this is different
i am sending it back into his cesar
position
i'm really exaggerating that part you
see
i'm not just leaning and then he tilts
i'm i am displacing his seizure making
his hips
slide off of his body so he's
doing this over and over okay there he
goes
just doing it he comes up
i want to understand uh how to connect
to his center
okay and it doesn't matter if you do the
same one over and over you're still
feeling it
okay and then he goes
there you go
find it you gotta do the connection good
okay okay
okay in this drill
i know you have the kazushi patterns
okay so yes
and that is the most efficient way but
i'm not doing that in this drill so if
you pay attention
he goes he doesn't come forward you see
and he comes
up extends his upper leg he's on his
knee he
he's right he never comes out of the
seizure
okay so even though i'm yielding i'm
just
keeping him in the seizure so this goes
into his stance they're not like this
and then
here yield one
ah
not like that okay now two things as you
try to develop yourself is that i'm very
relaxed you see how relaxing
and then the second thing is that when i
take his
energy and i have it set up uh
the coq projection so i
i have the idea to push he's he can't
come in
because we're stuck okay i i when i come
around
i wouldn't lose his arm i'm stuck you
see how i'm
doing that okay and it's all done very
relaxed
you see but what i'm going to try to do
as opposed to having a very
active cooking i more use the i
key to set up your you see
i i'm i'm bridge i am using the i key to
load my co cube
can you see that so here is the
difference so here's
here is the i key do you see and then
and here is the active
you see that what i'm going to do you
push right
see that's that's where i want to be
okay and that's very difficult to do
unless i'm relaxed
if i if i stay relaxed then it'll
happen easy and the reason i lose
tension is because i feel threats
involved or the reason i create tension
is i feel threatened by you or by
extension
i want to throw you which is still i
feel threatened by you
so i'm just doing these energy keep an
energy drill
and uh part of the training is as we
don't have to but it'll help
um a lot of times you'll have contagion
so you feel be relaxed and then you
forget your role and you you're not
pushing because i'm not pushing you okay
so you have to keep your roll there you
go
i again of course it looks fake like you
people don't know what they don't know
so it
what it is okay but you want to do the
art
you have to get to these skills
can you can't move your feet around but
you can also uh
not move your feet around uh and you
want to do the same thing i'm very
relaxed
and uh i am having you get to cook you
not me doing it actively okay so again
this would be me
see that okay so instead i'm very
relaxed
and you you hit so you don't see me do
that
you get it okay so very relaxed and you
can
i if i get overwhelmed i can move my
feet and then
of course it's gonna be more a little
more challenging
[Music]
and again it's always your face all
right right now i don't want to
i don't want to do it here and then
get the kazushi pattern i'm just
interested in your base displacement
face displacement
and it's not a matter of just pushing
back
all right look here forward
up
okay